present some of the work that we've been
working on in Daft uh we actually gave a
presentation last year at P Global 2022
when daap was just a few months old so
I'm really excited to show everyone you
know what we've been working on and some
of the the recent updates and how kind
of the whole vision of The Da data frame
is really really coming together um
during this session I'll be doing a
bunch of demos which will take a little
bit of time to run sometimes between a
minute or two so feel free to drop your
questions at the chat and we can
actually jump into those questions as we
go through uh the demos when whenever we
have time uh in between so let's get
started um just a little bit about me uh
so yeah I'm a co-founder at a company
called eventual um we're the ones
maintaining Daft um prior to this I've
worked at biotech and autonomous driving
mostly working on distributed Data
Systems building these data systems for
machine learning workloads um dealing a
lot with Cloud infrastructure a lot with
distributed data infrastructure Etc and
now I'm a core maintainer of Daft and
you can find us at dubdub duub get
da. um so first what what is Daft uh I
find it easier to show rather than tell
so I'm going to go ahead and share a uh
notebook where it might be easier to
just get a feel for what Daft is just by
looking at the notebook so first of all
Daft is a python Library you can easily
install Daft with Pip you do pip install
get Daft and you'll get all of our
prepackaged uh uh wheels from pipy um
it's a d is a cloud native data frame
API right so if you're familiar with
librar such as pypar polers pandas dask
uh these libraries of all have kind of a
data frame API um very similarly in in
Daft you can you can load data frames of
various data sources and when you you
show the data frame this is what the
data frame looks like it has rows and it
has columns in this case there's three
columns the path size and num RS column
each column has a type right utf8 in uh
64 and then this is the data within that
column right and so D allows you to load
from a bunch of different sources it's
very Cloud native um it even allows you
to do things in this case I'm actually
globbing a cloud path and returning a
data frame of all the files from within
that path
right um and then you know obviously we
also support reading csvs par Json and
reading you know thousands of these
files uh at at a single time um just
through these simple apis and you just
have to give it kind of this S3 prefix
to say hey I'm trying to hit this S3
Source um in in the
cloud um and yep so Daft is a data frame
we have all the other data frame
operations that you've you know we've
all come to expect like join two tables
together uh sort the data frame create a
new column using transformations of
previous columns filter a data frame Etc
um and that also supports a full kind of
CPAs query Optimizer to optimize your
queries before actually executing so
that's all fine and good right but what
makes Daft special there's a whole bunch
of data frame libraries out there why
did we TR build Daft uh and what what
what is the special s us and so D is
really good at what we call complex data
types so these are things such as you
know URLs and images and tensors and
these are types uh in Daft that are uh
defined in our on our data frame um but
when you you define the operations in
Python so like this you say you know
perform a URL download on the path
column and then perform an image decode
on the uh new data column and da will
then actually run everything in Rust
which makes it really really fast uh we
use a lot of uh cool async rust and bind
it to python to make this work
um but yeah so you'll notice here that D
has you know native types for um byes
columns called this data column is type
binary and then we have also native
types for image columns in this case uh
these are the images that we've
downloaded from these URLs so it's
really easy to go from you know URLs
like binary data to images to resize
images to tensors all these data
processing uh tools are kind of built
into Daft uh uh for you and run really
really efficiently and last of all da is
uh distributed meaning that we support
execution buil on a local python
multi-threaded back end which is what
I'm using right now this is running on
my laptop uh or if you need to use a
cluster of machines you can connect it
to a ray cluster it's very simple to do
that you just kind of call this daff
context set run array then now all of a
sudden Your da data frame with the same
syntax has access to you know thousand
cores and U terabytes of memory uh if
you run stuff in the cloud um so that's
kind of a brief introduction to to Daft
and some of the motivations behind why
we wanted to built Daft uh uh and saw
this Gap at the ecosystem for
distributed data frames that were really
really good at this type of data
processing um yeah and today's uh so so
what's what's new since last year right
so since last year we've built in a lot
of our rust core internals in depth uh
we've seen tremendous speed UPS in dep
execution through that we've built a lot
of native types like images and tensors
and Tings URLs and operations on those
types we've also been running a lot of
benchmarks you can check out our blog uh
to to see how fast we run on one
terabyte worth of a very typical
database tpch Benchmark um and today's
talk we're going to talk about how Daft
has really really built on its uh IO
layer to pull data very very efficiently
from S3 uh and the CL in general and so
to motivate the top why do we care about
Cloud IO performance in the first place
right um I'd argue that it's probably uh
the most important thing when when we're
talking about performance of data frame
libraries uh in the real world because
often times the data doesn't just sit on
your machine the data you know sits
somewhere in the cloud right so this is
kind of the setup usually for a real
world scenario of querying data uh you
have object storage something like AWS
S3 which we will be using in our demos
today and you have your query engine
this can be pendas polers uh Daft uh
ppar any Cory engine really the Cory
engine might be distributed meaning that
it's it's installed across multiple
nodes and machines
um and now the first thing you have to
do when you run any query right is you
need to pull down data from object
storage that's like fundamental you need
to grab the data pull it down uh to to
your machines right and then the second
thing that's really really expensive
ensive and these query engines is inter
node communication right because the
nodes need to shuffle data amongst each
other um for today's talk we'll focus on
the first part which is how do we you
know download and dze as little data as
fast as possible from object storage
right and how how can we make this super
super efficient so that in the first
place we can get data down so that the
query engine can then work on it um and
how do we measure what is considered
good performance so for the demos today
I'll be running Daft on the local py
Runner um on the R5 8X large machine
type it has these characteristics uh the
network performance advertised by AWS is
10 gigabits per second and so if we can
hit that 10 gigabits per second then we
know that we're being really efficient
with all the network bandwidth that's
being provided to us um this machine is
fairly large it has 32 cores and 256
gigabytes of uh memory but we'll also
see that we're able to process very very
large dats sets um even with this uh uh
uh uh setup
and uh yeah so without further Ado oh
one last thing uh just to help people
orientate around what we all the tools
that we're using I'm going to be using a
tool called iftop um which when you run
it it will tell you information such as
the total amount of data received since
the start of I oftp um the peak uh
amount of uh data that the peak
bandwidth that was uh uh running since
the start of IOP and also uh the average
uh receiving bandwidth over the last two
10 and 40 seconds and so I'll be
referring to these numbers quite a bit
as we go through the demo um because
we'll be able to see how much data is
actually flowing through the network on
that machine um cool so now that we've
got through all the kind of boring
pieces let's go straight to the demos um
I'm going to be running Daft in real
time and
um let me now share the other
screen all right um so yeah this this
notebook right now is actually running
in uh on an ec2 instance so I'm going to
restart iftop uh at at the bottom here
we'll see the if toop instance running
oh I don't know if let's see I can't
drag my my face away so uh let me make
this screen smaller so that we can all
see the
bottom
whoops I drag it to the
side H it's okay we'll I guess we'll try
to take a look at the uh the peak usage
instead of the uh the running usage
because I can't seem to get my face out
of the bottom right of this screen share
um let me try one more
thing to the
side yeah that's unfortunate um but I
think we'll try and look at the PE
memory utilization instead which often
times isn't as accurate but we'll see so
first of all I'm going to use Daft now
to just read a bunch of parket files
this is about uh 2 22 GB worth of parket
files which is about uh 44 GB uh when
decompressing memory and so when I run
Daft and I start reading data we'll see
that um in this case actually you can't
really see it on this screen share but
um iftop is also overflowing for some
reason but it Peaks at about 9 gigabits
per second which is really really good
right because um ah thank you the screen
share works now uh so so you can see
that it Peaks at about 9 gbits per
second um and this query will complete
in about 30
seconds oh whoops let me restart this
kernel I think the kernel
crashed and I'll restart I have top as
well um and yeah so so D is able to
really make use of the uh nwork
bandwidth here super efficiently it's
pulling data at about 9 gbits per second
um this is very simple query is just
grab all the paret files put it into a
DA data frame right um and so we expect
it to be able to parallelize in SV super
efficiently let's now we can try uh what
if we only wanted two uh columns from
our data frame right um da does perform
a whole bunch of very interesting
optimizations here um without
optimizations you'll see that da will
attempt to run a projection on top of
the scan but then if we run
optimizations Daft will understand that
hey this projection actually I can just
read two columns from the scan instead
so it will fold that projection into
into your scan operation and now it will
say hey projection push down I only want
to read two columns from these parquet
files right and so we'll see now when I
run this um that the uh Network
bandwidth is goes up to about five five
uh gbits per second um and it's very
very fast this completed in in 3 seconds
right pulling all that data down because
it only needed two columns and so D is
able to use you know that from par par
is a for column in the format and only
grabs two columns uh and it's able to
pull down this data incredibly gly from
this three um the next thing I wanted to
show you which is I think super cool is
what if you didn't want specific columns
you wanted specific rows right and you
give it this predicate um which is we're
saying now you know give me only rows
where the uh the l order key column has
values less than 100 right and so if you
run this that is actually able to do
this very very quickly naively you would
think that you would need to pull all
the data down run this predicate across
all the rows just to to get the the rows
but because par has a lot of interesting
metadata about those rows da can
actually make use of that metadata to
very intelligently prune out uh files
even that it doesn't have to read and so
this query where you would think you
might need to pull down the entire data
set of 22 gigabytes da is able to do in
two two and a half seconds right and
this is reading from S3 um and it's able
to do this incred incredibly quickly um
uh yeah with without having to pull the
actual data down this is what we call
inaf metadata
execution so the next thing I wanted to
show is kind of very near and dear to my
heart I think uh I've been working on a
bunch of problems relating to uh many
many small files in um the the the cloud
where let's say you have you know 10,000
100,000 small files in the cloud how
does that perform there right so we've
actually been running a lot of
optimizations around this um the first
thing is you know um I'm not sure if
people have tried this but listing files
in S3 is actually incredible
painful and expensive um I've seen this
take minutes even on some certain large
data sets Unfortunately today I only can
show you I have a 10,000 files sitting
around and so I can show show that to
you the naive approach for listing these
files will take about let's
see uh two two and a half seconds right
this is listing files uh using the
Amazon boto 3 Library um which is you
know I I've written this code at least
20 times if I career here so far where
I'm just trying to list files let's see
how fast da can do the same query uh
listing the files in the same bucket and
seeing prefix um using our from glob
path method it takes 300 milliseconds
right and this is because we're very
efficiently able to run these LS queries
and parallelize them uh for hierarchical
uh data data sets which is oftentimes a
case where you might have your data in
kind of a hierarchy of like year month
and date and dat is very very uh
efficient with listing those files in
this case it's listed about 10,000 files
uh across in this data set in in 300
milliseconds and this really adds up
because as you go up to 100,000 200,000
files right um the the time taken to
list files in a naive way will scale
linearly and uh Daft you know this this
globbing mechanism that D has is
actually integrated with everything else
if you're trying to read paret CSV and
you pass it to glob um D is able to to
um resolve those glovs very very quickly
so that's the first thing you have to
deal with when you deal with small files
just listing is expensive um the second
thing is that um you know can we read uh
10,000 small CSV files and the answer is
yes we can and one way that daap does
this is that um this same bucket with
you know 10,000 small CSV files when you
try to read in dep it actually coales a
lot of these files into one what we call
Micro partition um and we do this
because we know that these files are
small and we can kind of batch the reads
to these files to make them incredibly
efficient right so this is going to run
for about a minute um and we'll see that
you know the bandwidth usage goes up to
about two 2.5 gigabits per second which
is not great um but it's actually like
already pretty good uh and there are the
the def team we looked at there I we
were laughing because there's actually a
whole bunch of inefficiencies here and I
think we're actually bother here not by
bandwidth and by CPU um the dualization
of csvs is fairly expensive and so this
is something we're working on um but
yeah reading 10,000 files Works
flawlessly right now you do a bunch of
coing of the files so while this is
running maybe I can answer one question
from Martin if you have faster ey on S3
with rust S3 FS GCS FS would definitely
be interested please contribute back um
yeah we'll be we'll be interested in in
collaborating the problem with uh the
fspc libraries is that they assume uh
file system semantics over S3 right
which is oftentimes not the best way of
thinking about S3 there's a whole bunch
of assumptions around read ahead
buffering and stuff that doesn't really
uh work well in in in a lency bound
system like S3 and so we've actually
custom built a lot of the things in DFT
to to be uh you know highly parallel
reads do a lot of like replanning up
front to understand um you know ranges
and sizes of things that we need to read
from this three um cool so let's move
ahead with the demo again we finished
reading those uh 10,000 CSV files uh in
uh about one minute um PE that about 2
gbits per second 2 and a half gigabits
per second um and the next thing I
wanted to show you is you know often
times when you deal with complex data
unstructured data you might have a data
frame full of like URLs pointing out to
different sources right um so one
example could be a data frame like this
where I'm just reading a bunch of JPEG
files right give me a data frame full of
paths to the JPEG files and then I want
to call URL download on those JPEG files
um in this case I have a magic number
here we're trying to figure out how to
do this more intelligently um but when
we run this URL download we can see that
like the rate goes up to it should go up
to about 9 GBS uh per second it's just
maxing out this instance basically and
reading these uh JP files super super
efficiently there's about 40,000 files
here JPEG files and it's going to be
able to do this in about 20 seconds um
because we're maxing out kind of the
bandwidth utilization on on this machine
and there we go this is um about 13
gigabytes worth of data if we were
observing the uh total kind of uh memory
that was flowing through it was about 13
gigabytes and we did this in about uh 20
seconds at a 9 GBS per second uh uh
throughput which is really really cool
makes this basically mix you know
reading tons of small tiny uh JPEG files
and tons of small tiny say nump arrays
super efficient using DFT and loading
that into into the data frame is
incredibly efficient and the last thing
is you know uh if we weren't running a
toy example let's say you running uh
actual query uh this is tpch query on a
one terabyte data set question one of
tpch which is a database Benchmark if
you were running this uh you'll see that
you know Daft will peek at about in this
case I believe this will take about two
minutes to run um but it Peaks at about
7 and a half uh gigabits per second um
which is fairly good it's about 1
Gigabyte per second um on this machine
it's not quite saturating the machine um
but that's also you know that's it's a
function of like how many cores are
available on the machine and how hard D
is pushing the resource uh utilization
on this machine you'll notice that this
q1 query is actually super iio bound
most of the work is upfront and this
like scan uh scan and then run a couple
of things basically um because yeah the
workload is IO bound once we pass scan
the workload completes incredibly uh
fast um so I'm going to hop over to
questions while this is running um let's
see so Daniel's asking if AWS Wrangler
is plan and not currently but if you uh
uh join our slack Channel and have some
suggestions on how you know um we might
be able to packet something like that
we'd be interested in learning more um
and yeah so uh Shaw had a had a question
what is the the window at the bottom uh
this was earlier in the talk uh but this
is a program I'm running called if top
uh it shows you um the rate of uh
network uh throughput on on this machine
and so we're looking at this row which
is the RX row receiving um and then this
is the peak uh uh memory utilization um
sorry the peak uh Network through in in
the receiving
channels cool um so yeah this should
complete soon but I'll just hop over to
uh uh the main chat actually let's just
let it finish it should be done just
about soon I think it usually completes
in about 2 minutes and yeah so you'll
see that once we're done with the scan
all these other things are just so
incredibly fast right basically all all
the work that had to be done in this
query was reading domestically and once
that was done everything else was like
you know what was that five seconds um
so yeah that's Daft uh kind of uh some
of the demos I had to show for Daft uh
reading from S3 um and let's go back to
slides
uh so yeah some final closing thoughts
uh does it work at production scale uh
yes we've been working with Amazon uh
it's D is now reading pedabytes worth of
parket files uh daily at Amazon some
initial results from them is that
they've seen you know up to 38% increas
in uh in their workload cost efficiency
um because the workload is fairly iio
bound just reading par files from the
cloud um comparisons to other libraries
it's really hard to compare fairly right
the data is different the hardware is
different the networks are different
there was a really good talk at Piata
NYC 2023 just a couple of weeks ago
benchmarking spark dusk uh dctb and
Polaris highly recommend you give that
talk a watch um and just looking through
that talk you know I ran the tpch q1
Benchmark because that's kind of what
the talk dives into uh da performs
extremely well U given that we're using
a much smaller virtual machine for this
demo with less Network bandwidth um but
again I think the data formats and and
size and file sizes are very different
from what was used of talk and so it's
not exactly comparable but given that
we're you know maxing out the bandwidth
on on the machine uh I'm fairly
confident that DFT is doing pretty well
here
um and yeah now the main thing we're
working on right now at D's Integrations
with uh Technologies like Apache Iceberg
Delta Lake hoodie and Hive uh which give
us even more metadata on top of your
your files right it can tell us things
like oh for this file you know column X
has values between five and 100 and so a
Daft at the planning level can actually
do a lot of intelligent optimizations
around figuring out which files we need
to read which parts of the file we need
to read and doing a lot of intelligent
pruning there to make this even faster
um and uh if you like what you see come
chat with us we love to collaborate my
email address is actually down at the
bottom there so feel free to take that
down um yeah uh that's that's all I have
today and happy to take any questions uh
drop them in the
chat
so if there aren't any questions Daniel
actually if you're still in chat I'm
curious to learn more about what you
mean by um a convenience package like
AWS Wrangler I'm not familiar with AWS
Wrangler so if you wanted to elaborate
that could be useful or you know just
get in touch with me um on on my email
we also have a uh slack channel that we
use um a community slack channel so feel
free to get in touch with me
there
ah thank you okay so AWS Wrangler makes
it much easier to read and write to
Athena for example
um and makes the whole AWS iio to pandis
much easier yeah I've actually found
that like the uh High Arrow S3 file
system is not bad uh Daft is depending
on the workload uh can be much faster
than than the pi Arrow uh and I guess
the arrow C++ S3 reader it's not bad and
so if you are trying to read uh iio into
pandas um you can try using Daft which
is just Daft read and then you do do two
pandas that could work or you can also
just use the Pyro one which is I think
pyro par dot you know uh retable and you
have to pass in like a file system
object and then you convert that into
pandis um yeah but maybe I'm guessing
AWS Wrangler uh probably wraps some of
that to to make it
efficient yeah just as a quick uh uh I
guess clarification to the the
partnership we have with Amazon they
were previously using pyro and then they
sub substitute da in we were seeing
especially around around um much much uh
more aggressive column pruning reads we
are seeing that outperform pyro by quite
a bit
here um so what features of rust enabled
this uh yeah so we are actually using a
whole bunch of ASN rust in Tokyo which
is the which is a ASN rust run time um
and so we're able to run kind of
multi-threading rust multi-threading not
python multi-threading right so we
completely releas the Gill at that point
which makes it very very fast um and
then we are able to run all of our
operations in in Asic rust um on top of
that what we've done is also a fairly
sophisticated planning layer around
understanding
specifically which parts of a file we
need to read we do a lot of intelligent
batching of of requests um and retry
policies with awss 3 uh to to make all
this work um awss 3 has a rust SDK which
uh exposes a lot of the lower level kind
of H HTTP level um uh parameters that we
can use to uh very efficiently quy data
from S3 and and apply some intelligent
retry policies uh that can help us work
very well with uh AWS but we also expose
all of these parameters in a conf and so
if you have other S3 compatible storage
like minio or you know I think ozone is
another one or even a Seth cluster you
can actually tune these parameters so
that the da can be well behaved or
interacting with your S3 compatible
storage uh regarding Microsoft azure
we haven't optimized it for Microsoft
Azure it works with Microsoft Azure
right now we accept I think AZ uh colash
and EFS colon uh URLs but get in touch
with us uh we work ke into doing more
optimizations there as well given how
Azure is you know getting a lot of
prominence in P ml AI space in general
yeah get in touch with us my email is
there just drop me an
email I think we're at time right so um
Don feel free to take over